got chickens want to keep them alive and
thriving let's make it happen one buy
quality chicks from trusted suppliers
healthy chicks mean fewer losses two
protect them from extreme cold use good
brooders and central heating to keep
them cozy three avoid Suffocation keep
the temperature even and avoid loud
noises four always wash Drinkers and
replace water daily clean water is a
must five serve water before feeds it
keeps chickens calm and prevents
stampedes six prevent diseases know the
risks get advice and vaccinate seven
never use moldy feeds it's dangerous and
can make them sick eight keep Predators
out secure your pens from dogs cats and
snakes nine follow medication and
vaccination schedule strictly it's a
lifesaver 10 prevent ammonia build up in
litter clean dry litter means healthy
Birds 11 maintain proper hygiene it
stops diseases from entering your farm
12 Supply sufficient feed wellfed birds
are healthy Birds follow these tips to
reduce poultry mortality and boost your
profits happy farming subscribe